I'm a brave person,
what a
noodle acting.
This is the confirmation of our value.
Everyone
wants everyone to accuse Yukimuroguchi
.
I can suck it up
Oh, of course I won't betray you There's no
such
thing Someone will betray you because they want points
And what is
Abal Yukimura isn't a
retiree I told him I was a retiree
Exchanged mobile phones with
Ichinose's actions  It was unexpected, but
this is
Eddie
[music]
The real owner of that form is Ayanokouji-gumi, right
?
I still don't know the number of 's,
ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah
ah  It's time to
go back to your room It
seems like you were a tempt d-class
, why do you believe everyone?
result